foreign
[Music]
networking demo Series in this video we
will be talking about multi-cloud
private DNS my name is Ashira and I'm a
network specialist customer engineer
based out of Sunnyvale
I'm super excited to cover this topic
with you so if you're ready then let's
get started
as customers expand their Cloud
footprint Beyond a single cloud provider
the need to establish a private Network
infrastructure between the various Cloud
providers becomes even more important
now one of the crucial aspects of the
private Network infrastructure is the
need for private DNS endpoint resolution
between the cloud providers and one of
the reasons for this is that the
applications hosted on one cloud
provider will need to access the
resources hosted on the other cloud
provider and advice versa so in this
demo we'll take a common
multi-cloud private DNS scenario walk
through some sample requirements and
then present a solution demo
now let's look at a common customer
scenario
the customer has applications already
hosted on both clouds and is in the
midst of a multi-cloud expansion the
application hosted in AWS needs private
DNS resolution for Google Cloud hosted
resources and vice versa they already
have a high availability VPN tunnel
established between both the cloud
providers and they would like us to use
this connectivity option as well
now let's walk through the customer
requirements
the number one being a private and
secure DNS resolution between both
clouds and along with that ensuring High
availability
also one of the requirements are around
using both clouds managed offerings in
the solution as much as possible as that
would ensure less operational toil
and lastly they would like us to come up
with the cost effective solution as you
know cost is something that is a
requirement for their business
so let's look at the DNS and network
routing flow for inbound forwarding of
the DNS queries that is from the AWS ec2
instances to the spoke one and spoke to
uh domain names so the ec2 instances
located in AWS in both the spoke vpcs
send the query to their local DNS
resolver and Port the Route 53
forwarding rules they get forwarded to
the Route 53 outbound endpoint
associated in the hub VPC
now the Route 53 outbound endpoint then
forward the DNS query to Cloud DNS and
Cloud DNS receives the queries via DNS
inbound server policies and forwards
these queries to the perspective spoke
vpcs as the it has a DNS viewing
established between uh itself and the
individual spoke vpcs now from a network
routing standpoint the transit Gateway
eni that is
present in both the spoke vpcs has an
attachment to the AWS Transit Gateway
and the AWS Transit Gateway already has
routes in its routes route table to
forward traffic to the cloud router or
the Google Cloud via AWS side to side
VPN connection so that's how the routing
of the requests work
now let's look at the DNS and network
routing flow for the outbound forwarding
side of things so the Google Cloud VMS
essentially send the DNS queries to the
spoke one and spoke to
multidns.aws.com so the from a DNS
standpoint the query from each of the
spoke vpcs is sent to the cloud DNS
local resolver and as you can see and we
are DNS peering it gets routed to the
DNS forwarding Zone in the hub VPC the
DNS forwarding zone or send the DNS
queries to the inbound endpoint that is
associated with the Hub VPC now the
Route 53 resolver inbound endpoint uses
the VPC plus 2 resolver and the private
hosted Zone that's associated with the
Hub VPC already has records for the
spoke one dot multi DNS Dot aws.com and
spoke to Dot
multidns.ews.com and that's how the
query resolution works now when it comes
to routing the cloud router actually
advertises custom routes uh that is the
slash now team route to to the AWS
Transit Gateway and in the AWS Transit
Gateway already has the route for the
slash 19 dynamically propagated in its
route table
and so does all the individual tgw
subnets in the spoke vpcs have that
route as well
so that essentially from a routing
standpoint the
AWS Transit Gateway receives the routes
and then it forwards it to the
individual spoke vpcs through the eni
attachment
so now let's uh look at the network
infrastructure this diagram represents
that and uh I've already gone ahead and
created this on my end in the interest
of time
just walking through what I have set up
we have three projects on Google Cloud
one is the Hub project and two spoke
projects each of these projects have
vpcs in them I've already spun up GCE
instances in each of the spoke vpcs and
uh the resources and all of the projects
are launched in the U.S east 4 region
and that's one of the requirements that
is that are called out in our best
practices doc
now on the AWS side there are three vpcs
as well one Hub VPC and two spoke vpcs
both the spoke vpcs have ec2 instances
launched in them uh
and all of the instances are running in
the U.S east one region or rather all of
the resources as well
now an AJ side to side VPN connection
already exists so between Google cloud
and AWS
such that there are four tunnels on the
Google side and two VPN connections
terminating on AWS Transit Gateway on
the AWS side and each VPN connection has
two tunnels each so that's a brief
overview
so now before starting the demo I just
want to call out that this demo will for
the most part focus on setting up the
DNS configuration on the Google Cloud
side and thus in the interest of time
I've already created the following
components or resources in the AWS Route
53 console
so I've gone ahead and created a private
hosted Zone in AWS Route 53 with the
record name multi DNS or aws.com and it
has each of the scope VPC records in
them as you can see
I also went ahead and created an inbound
endpoint this is the resolver ID and
while creating the endpoint I also
attached a security group that has rules
that allow incoming traffic from the
Google Cloud DNS IP addresses via the
TCP UDP port 53. and it also has two
endpoint inbound endpoint IPS for
availability
and I would suggest keeping a note of it
for future configuration also the subnet
attached to these ipfab routes pointing
to the Google DNS IP uh that is the
35.199.192.019
[Music]
um pointing to Transit Gateway and we'll
see how so this is the software this is
the route table I filtered it with the
Hub VPC
and as you can see voila the slash 19 is
attached to Transit Gateway
now we'll move on the gcp side of
configuration and just a word of caution
to perform this demo on Google Cloud you
must enable the cloud DNS API and Grant
the necessary DNS permissions or IM
roles like DNS admin and DNS pure so
let's go ahead and create a Zone and
spoke project one
you're uh under the zones tab we'll hit
create Zone
and once we hit uh create Zone we will
and select private as the Zone type Zone
name would be spoke one dash multi Dash
gcp
multi1.gcp.com as the DNS name
keep the default as private Network
spoke one and hit create
and we can see the NS and soe Records
have already been created and we now
create the a record of spoke one
and point it to the ec2 instance
and then we'll also go ahead and create
the sport project too and I'll be right
back and there you can see
spoke2.multi2.gcp.com pointing to the
ec2 instance in spoke to now we look at
the inbound solver policies that I
already went ahead and created while I
was creating the VPC in the hub project
it is named as AWS inbound
inbound query forwarding is turned on in
use by The Hop project and this is the
an IP that you need to keep note of as
we'll be using it in future
configurations uh during aws's outbound
endpoint creation these are nothing but
Regional internal IPS that Google
allocates to the inbound server policies
so just something to keep note of
so now we'll proceed with creating DNS
peering for uh both the directions given
its unidirection uh we would need to
create two DNS viewing so and said Hub
and then one each in the sport project
so in the hub project you hit create
Zone select Zone type private go to Sam
you know put out whichever The Zone name
that you like now in the DNS name we
would add the one that's assigned to the
private hosted zone of the spoke one
project which in our case is
multi1.gcp.com
and then in the options you'll keep the
options as DNS peering you'll select the
network as hub
for the pure project you'll select spoke
to spoke project one pure Network spoke
one and there you go
this is the spoke one pairing from The
Hub VPC we'll create a similar one for
spoke to originating from hub I will go
ahead and create this appearing along
with the spoke bearings and get back
I'll
yeah so there you go this is the Hub
spoke to peering the DNS name is
multi2.gcp.com
your network is spoke to and similarly
in the spoke project 2 we'll create
appearing to uh ew2 to the hub project
where the DNS name is
multidns.ews.com which is the private
hosted Zone in AWS
uh and the network is spoke to similarly
we'll create one for spoke one now let's
create a forwarding Zone in our Hub
project
Zone type would be private or you can
put forwarding as your Zone name
multidns.aws.com because we are
forwarding queries to another server
and in and and the network would be Hub
now looking at the IP address we'll
select the two IP addresses for the
inbound endpoint that I asked you to
save earlier so you'll add that you'll
select private forwarding for both the
IPS
and hit create
this creates a forwarding Zone in your
Hub project to forward DNS queries to
AWS now we will modify the cloud router
routes as they have a default
advertisement enabled on it we will uh
basically change it to custom route
propagation and for to do that we'll go
to the cloud routers under hybrid
connectivity uh console click on edit
and uh then we will select create custom
route select advertise all subnets
um and then you know create a new custom
route with a custom IP range to
35.199.192.0 19. which is the cloud DNS
range uh and then add a description hit
save and then we'll go to the AWS side
of the console and go all the way down
to Transit Gateway route tables
which you can see right there and we'll
hit refresh because the view hasn't been
updated and there we see the slash 19
route being propagated uh from from
Google Cloud
now we'll move on to creating an
outbound endpoint
that and we'll see how to do that I
already created it actually and uh
interested in the interest of time so
I'll just review of the configuration so
I it's basically it has a security group
it is attached to the host that is the
Hub VPC we also assigned uh we'll have
to assign to IPS to the outbound
endpoint for high availability in each
of the easies and then we'll create two
outbound rules for this outbound
endpoint the rule type would be forward
the domain name would be
multi1.gcp.com which is the spoke one
side of the gcp and attach all the three
vpcs for correct routing of the request
and uh in the IPS what we'll do is we'll
add the inbound server policy IP that we
got uh in in the in gcp
and then we'll start testing
basically we'll create another endpoint
uh another rule for spoke to as well
which I already did now let's run a dig
from the AWS ec2 spoke one instance to
uh or we can do an NS look up to to the
spoke one
DNS domain
that works we will also do that for
spoke to and that works as well now
let's run the same commands from the
spoke to AC to instance and the ports
seem to be working
that's awesome
great so basically our outbound uh are
forwarding from AWS to gcp is working or
you can call it inbound free forwarding
to gcp you can name it any which way now
let's see from the gcp side of things
does the forwarding work to AWS
seems like the spoke one we spoke to VPC
has it working
just running both those commands
and looks like we have successful
resolution
to get more information on cloud DNS
best practices please read the
documentation on the slide deck and
check out the links in the description
have a good day foreign
[Music]